here's Lowrie slide
[Applause]
yes he dresses by recovering on that
blame picked us out
Kyle usually gets us play but just
forgets to block what to say than a
recognition of time on the clock to
knock the battle
good hands by theis well outsider that
was smart better pass bounce back potato
closer to exactly where he was
take a look at this good play coming up
and I tell you when you play basketball
like that over you miss a a good
opportunity pocket let's play back
my red van
his nails shot into the body is smart
and somehow gets that English up on a
glass beautiful point look at a backspin
here Maddie that's big-time control
[Applause]
Rogier with the weak side help and flop
solid revenue doesn't go in Ventura with
rebound VanFleet pushing it
[Applause]
appreciated by Ibaka
ball down the floor but nothing more
special about Freddy don't make it look
so easy like to see William get some
touches on both hands down rosier to the
past
Negros ain't just explodes take a look
at this bike you like it they like it
[Applause]
van fleet goes right out to Remco top
shadow banks at home how do we get that
one to go well just isolated is very
good defense by Joep go but a tremendous
minute down take Sexton takes the jumper
[Applause]
the first half
half of his life here
eight four eight five to shoot
Leonard sees the double-team they in
fleet boys stood up that's a two-pointer
not naked girl with the pass inside and
sabonis with the Miss Rose you could
have it
[Applause]
Deana Pacers in the third quarter
Big Shot Pyro's here let's go to the
fourth on TNT Leonard trying to get the
ball Curry's on him there's lots of
double-team vendors trying to split
almost traveled and we close it up
[Applause]
rainbow prevented sleep for they doubled
van wie
gets it and knocks it home
to Delphi Yahoo celery yep
Rozier since the cops
in the open court I want to see more of
this this year as he goes keeps it high
gets the contact and the friendly bounce
got a good one here I'm Chapel Hill he
to hand in the face he's headed back
toward the bench
here's VanFleet trying to create and he
drills it big buck at that time
Rozier whoa spins into a deep three and
don't go away yet they're 1 of 10 from
three-point range
they shot a season low 6-4 31
[Applause]
stead cent has none better for the game
a young team is what he said he would
prefer wait knocks it down over birds Oh
throws it away ago there was the race to
the ball trying it smart with that got
the three I'm just gonna say that but
could look at smart high hands make that
pass dominant breathe Terry Rozier the
best at closing those gaps there's open
underneath here's Van Vleet drives kicks
Lowry big-time possession at time action
right here look at it down the clock
shot clocks about the flow and then
gets it too badly splash shot selection
needs to be better I feel like he gets
he got frustrated out there because as
Rozier lays in it bands lead
Danny Green pops out high entry pass
this denial by Morris van plea from
Victoria the action they try to go
inside the pocket gets blocked good
heads-up play tremendous shot
preparation on against Mirotic potato to
the hole left hand sends Randall's still
two seconds left bruise here three the
Celtics on fire here in the first
quarter him sleep through it
yeah siakam his first field goal Raptors
have cut it to two chips here to tie
they do is give it a rosier
pull-up three
[Applause]
[Music]
two and a half to play in a second bam
bleep good operator finds Ibaka of a
two-man play smart Davis got tangled up
over the top there's bars for two to
play by Terry Rozier coming up the floor
watch this lob pass to Morris finds the
ladder go gets it kisses it off the
glass it side there he was on well he
had two back-to-back 20s going in both
games 7 of 9 from the field into the
lion badly
[Music]
got a little push on the back there for
bein the ball alive this is great job
we've got the ball both ends of the
floor those ears
go cut off ground now see a complete one
[Applause]
Crozier
Quetzal a a fighter
now fastest speed wall I think there's
about four point five one way the other
way left-hand layup good luck sort of
being aggressive with the rock walk down
to two here's Fred launching the free
that's good and a big bucket ready van
to bleep takes it nicely
[Applause]
Oh hustle at all nice play by ceiling
Brown - Rozier for the throwdown
Ibaka target box rocked in double palm
spread from another number five for Fred
from people on the shot clock
Heywood kicks it back Rozier passed up
the tree now takes it
[Applause]
[Music]
and our ball gets kick there's to pump
their step there's the foul there's
three there's a hand signal much Gary
Terry
no doubt about that foul your spread
gloss over gets a little bit a good
steady Freddie
[Applause]
wanna shake right there and Fred with
the shake right here
pick that move
in Boston 1 out of 19 to to run after
trailing by six of this Kate
a chance for a four-point play iron is
kind Mike look at the elevation didn't
really see the foul but touch up and use
all the rim as he drops for the
old-fashioned elite company in terms in
a record and elite why not a third guy
in the old segment is Van Winkle
misdirection and one that stay
it's the switch great finish
kicks it out young makes it to the
basket by Rozier Freddie
knocks it down he's got 30 Rozier gets
it the passing lane throws it out front
finishes
the Bible is shot [ __ ] man sleep
[Applause]
[Music]
all the way to the bucket for Tuesday's
year
my said you have to have go one way
cross over get down he'll take the hit
finish off the glass see act them five
on the shot clock
[Music]
and bleep horses up a runner and hits
nothing but net they've got time guys
stop the ball here's those ear steps
into a three yep
you can see it come did the same thing
at their house in that last game yep yep
for Oklahoma City by Bowie to go in the
third period and please count that no
doubt about that one late Matt
freshwater to a 2 so the end of one who
was 22 tries for the squirrel looks a
little bit different they went over in
reviewed give over Joey here he comes
again walk here by Terry Rozier let's
though thinks he has a wide-open layup
get the step
nice recover here defensive and he said
he's completely comfortable with this
squad and he thinks that they're in the
right position heading towards the
postseason Matt chose to shot secretion
as different guys to try to see if they
can retain them but nobody's really been
able to do it this season
shot clock down Van Vleet step-back
three got it this spot but not playing
like a 50 here tonight is low here you
watch the games actually every night I
would say you know well that's a little
[Music]
definitely has a different feel the
contact does he get it right back at it
with another one of those league team
that unfortunately lost to Long Island
last night single elimination what a
great year
congratulations to javo first year red
veined I think to me that's a as big a
factor as it is the statistical element
as well gee
[Applause]
whose ears Faro right all with the head
of it Rozier up the plaza
knocking it down Terry Rozier 10 points
in the first quarter
56% as well the efficiency is great
turnover thread
[Applause]
[Music]
seven Elrod
dominant performance great D right here
I think fun containment and police smart
Lydia time for Hayward kick out to
Rozier three under shot I let that
alright your final 141 12 may be knocked
out in Terry Rozier at the buzzer 142
115 shot clock to five
fires two three
[Applause]
[Music]
kinda sand way he
it's a switch here little stop the go
backs it up steps back for a tree and
buries it it's gonna be a long two but
what a shot by Terry Rozier you filete
so show him why he was first team All
Defense
the last three ballgames look at this
side and step through here
by feel this underway here in Washington
repeated again they still trying to
guard Kawhi Leonard fans lead off the
dribble contested shot is good but what
a difficult shot verb and bleep Fred Van
Fleet has been great at both ends of the
floor with the next revolt then
therefore I can tank if we are all bad
teams we lose 47% of our games then get
the sole fake strives 1 on the shot
clock man bleep one dribble gets the
prey Fred Perry that's the shot clock
expires
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content